speaking of time do you believe time to
be well maybe you don't let's not say
believe when you were playing with some
ideas earlier and you're saying well
time may be emergent do you also believe
space to be emergent do you believe
space time itself is
emergent yeah I mean if if if time is
emergent it's hard for me to imagine
that space is not emergent too again
anybody who's uh spent a little time
thinking about the insights from
Einstein on recognizes that space and
time are so deeply and intricately
interwoven into the fabric of space time
that sort of pulling one apart and
imagining it has different properties
space and time have different properties
it's not impossible but it does fly in
the face of pretty much everything we've
learned in the last 100 years so I
certainly do Envision that if there's a
realm of reality in which time does not
apply because as we were saying the
condition having yet allowed for a
conception of time to emerge the same
would almost certainly be true of space
so the real way of saying it is is there
a realm of reality in which there's no
conception of
SpaceTime and and it's hard for me to
imagine what that is but that's because
I've got this brain that is constrained
by what my ancestors did and that brain
is one that is so tied to a conception
of reality in which space and time are
the architecture within which events
take place that it's really hard for us
to think about a reality in which there
isn't SpaceTime and so I I wish I could
give some really good uh example or
insight into what that would be like but
it would be some kind of reality in
which the language that we use would not
talk about when things are happening and
the language that we use would not talk
about where things are happening the
language would somehow be beneath that
more fundamental than that and it's not
that scientists don't have some ideas
for what this might be like but I'd say
that we do lack the Deep picture and the
Deep story of how we would really
articulate navigate a reality absent
SpaceTime have you had a chance to go
through Wolf's Theory his project on
physics wish I had you know yeah I mean
you
know you Steve's a great guy and he's a
friend and um we talk about things on
occasion and um I wish I had more time
to to spend with him because it's always
Illuminating when we do spend some time
together
but I've I've
not I don't feel like I fully grasp the
approach that he's taking um and why I
oh well well I can absolutely throw this
on myself um so it could well be
limitations in my own thinking and
limitations the amount of energy and
effort that I've expended to understand
his his approach more fully um but I get
stuck on trying to really understand
whether the
formalism as he envisions it is it
actually fundamentally different from
the more traditional formalism he would
say yes as far as I can tell but as I
have looked at it on occasion it has
struck me that it's not obvious to me
that it is as different as He suggests
and again I could be wrong on this and
it could be that I just haven't put put
enough effort or energy into it I'm glad
that he's pursuing his approach it's not
within the confines of the traditional
established environment is not doing it
inside of a physics department or math
department you know he has the resources
and and and the creative energies to
make his own environment and find his
own collaborators and and more power to
anybody who who has the capacity to do
that whether it's going to Bear the
fruit that he envisions I don't know but
I'd say the same thing about what we're
doing here like we've been beating down
on string theory you know since you know
1984 at least you know the the big first
Revolution but since 1968 if you want to
go further back to the first glimmers of
string theory and where are we now 2023
that's a lot of years right so you can
say the same thing you know so so I
don't feel qualified to really judge the
approach but I I just feel that I
haven't fully wrapped my head around
whether or not it's fundamentally
different from what we
do quite a few thoughts firstly what
progress has been made in string theory
in the past say two
decades yeah well that's a a nice big
chunk of time and I'd say you know the
big thing in the last two decades has
been the the
recognition
that there's a connection between
gravity and quantum
mechanics that I don't think we
sufficiently appreciated 20 25 years ago
I mean I mean take my book just as As
One Moment In Time a snapshot in the the
elegate universe that was published in
1999 and in that book I I very clearly
lay out there's this Theory called
general relativity describing Gravity
the big stuff I lay out how there is
this other Theory called quantum
mechanics describing the small stuff and
we want to put them all together to have
a unified theory of the big and the
small but we're having trouble doing
that and then I go into the book and how
String Theory seems to be making
progress in putting the big and the
small together if I was writing that
book today and in some sense I am
because I'm adding a a chapter for the
25th anniversary of the elegant universe
and and one of the things that I'm
emphasizing
is there's now a lot of evidence that
gravity and quantum mechanics in some
sense are kind of the same Theory they
are already in some strange sense
combined and this was completely
unexpected based on anything that we
knew 20 or so 20 plus years ago so
within for instance general relativity
there are these structures you made
reference to one of them earlier called
wormholes which are tunnels in the
fabric of space going from one SpaceTime
location to another through a kind of
shortcut that's general relativity in
quantum mechanics there's this weird
thing called quantum entanglement where
two widely separated particles can act
as though they're right next to each
other even though they can be opposite
ends of the
universe and really nobody thought there
was a connection between these two ideas
until people like Lenny suskind and Juan
Mal DEA and and a variety of other
influential scientists who many to name
them all gave evidence that in some
sense wormholes and entanglement are
kind of the same thing they kind of feel
the same if you think about it Wormhole
it's connecting one point in SpaceTime
with another through a shortcut ENT
tanglement it's connecting one particle
in SpaceTime with another particle in
some sense through a shortcut because
they're acting as though they're right
next to each other and so this is the
beginning the tip of an iceberg of a
deep and and very powerful story which
is showing that structures in general
relativity and structures in quantum
mechanics are
already deeply connected and deeply
entwined and so the unification program
May ultimately not be described in terms
of putting gravity and quantum mechanics
together the way I described it many did
of course in the earlier days but it may
be more deeply understanding general
relativity more deeply understanding
quantum mechanics and more deeply
understanding how they are part and
parcel of the same theoretical structure
if you enjoyed that clip then the full
podcast is out right now you can click
around here enjoy subscribe to theories
of everything to get notified of
upcoming podcasts as there are new
fulllength podcasts every week on the
topics of mathematics physics
Consciousness Free Will and
AI